why did god allow sin to enter into a
perfect world what do you think adam sinned
adam sinned because he chose to sin
it was not an accident the bible is clear eve
was deceived adam was not first timothy chapter
2 excuse me 13 and 14. now sin was allowed because
the angels had to understand how god functions go
to first peter chapter one let's read verses 11
and 12. first peter chapter 1 verses 11 and 12.
this will tell us that the old testament
prophets while they were writing
did not fully understand what they were writing
but they had to be told they were writing for
another generation so we'll go to first
peter chapter one you read verses 11 and 12.
read very very carefully do you
have that first peter 1 11 and
12.
searching what or what manner of time the spirit
of christ which was in them did signify when it
testified beforehand the suffering of christ and
the glory that should fall now verse 12 unto whom
it was revealed that not unto themselves but unto
us they did minister to the things which are now
reported unto you by them that have preached the
gospel unto you finish that verse with the holy
ghost come down from heaven come on which things
the angels desire to look into which is the gospel
the angels do not understand everything now
compared to us their minds are like encyclopedias
don't misunderstand me but they don't
understand everything and so when lucifer fell
and the lord threw him out they did not
understand whether or not he was justly treated
as a matter of fact eli white writes in bible
commentary volume 5 page 11 49 paragraph
10 it was only when they saw what lucid
what satan did to christ on the cross
that the last strings of sympathy with satan
were cut imagine this for four thousand years
and more there were angels in heaven who
felt lucifer had been unfairly treated
god had to allow sin that's the reason why god
allowed cain to live that the universe may see
what happens as sin proceeds and progresses it's
a painful thing for god because he hates sin
hebrews 1 verse 9 thou hast love righteousness
and hated iniquity and the things we hate we
try to avoid god cannot avoid sin that's why
when all the wicked are finally destroyed
including satan but before he is destroyed
every knee shall bow and every tongue shall
finally confess that jesus christ is lord that
has to happen and for that to happen sin has
to be seen for what it really is so that those
of us who are saved having seen what sin does
we will choose to live in a world
where sin will never return again
so god had to let it happen and
proceed yes and god always knows best
that's why to please god you
must interact with him by faith
because he's god we're not and there's so
much it's like children and parents children
do not understand why the father the mother said
no the parents understand the child doesn't you